I see that Nicola is on social media a lot. I
talk to Misha, but I don't know the
reality and nature of the thing. This
Misha is humane, sweet and attractive. What did he bring to
her? It means that she is very humane. They do not want to
believe that he is this person who does not work, the
penniless one who has nothing to do, but he is...
He prays in his room in front of the Virgin. You come
alone like Misha and
tell him I love you and I want you. You met me
once with a 46-year-old girl. The last time I posted a girl wearing 16 years old.
16 years old and I caught a
Diwaniyah girl. I mean,
maybe because I was
deep with girls, I went
out with guys. I met guys, and not once did
I expect it to be me.  With a divorced woman, of course,
my mother will not like it. She made me crazy. Who is this
girl? Who is the girl? My mother.
Dot.